what would you say to that first-time
filmmaker that may not have a lot of
things to give away to their audience
for free but they've got a site they've
got a film whether it's a shorter
feature that's generating a lot of
interest what could they give away
that's not hey by this hey me me me what
is there something that's a value to the
people coming back trying to figure out
what's valuable you know as a filmmaker
what can I give a way to get some of
these email address or to build that
relationship a little bit more you know
it's going to vary project the project
and it's going to vary filmmaker to
filmmaker you know why is it that some
people were drawn and there's popular
filmmakers out there why are some people
drawn to Kevin Smith or ed burns or some
of those guys as opposed to somebody
that's just starting out yeah it's a
good question because there's some
filmmakers that are doing a subject
matter movie like I'm doing a movie on
cigars and if you sign up for my email
I'm going to give you a downloadable you
know poster of the movie right and some
people that are really into cigars
they'll say that's really valuable I
want it but me personally since I don't
smoke cigars I probably wouldn't find
that as valuable but if it were a
skateboarding documentary and I love
skateboarding and it was like a skype
conversation with one of the subjects in
the movie and that conversation happened
to be christian hosoi you know i would i
would definitely sign up for that email
address i definitely sign up to see
exclusive content that i couldn't get
anywhere else like I would love to see
like that interview with christian hosoi
or if I was a cigar aficionado I'd love
to see the inside view of the cigar
factory or if I was making the movie on
I'm just trying to think of a subject
matter some sort of love story movie and
I'm really into that kind of stuff I'd
love to see that beautiful panoramic
view of you know the beach with the
Clearwater and like this is where we're
shooting our location like that could be
very interesting to me but it's going to
vary because you're a first-time
filmmaker you're not Kevin Smith yet
you're not add burns you don't have
quite that following so it's like how do
you build that following and I think the
way to build it is one person at a time
one conversation at a time one piece of
value at a time
and you say if it is a short film maker
and they have a like a short that's
getting a lot of notoriety out there I
would almost say give away that short
for free give it away in exchange for an
email address
you